jesus
[Laughter]
all right y'all
and we back again let's go
[Music]
ladies and
gentlemen welcome back
to your
favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
what's up y'all guess what
married man i did it
got married i'ma briefly go over it i
was gonna have rachel on but i have some
technical difficulties so after our
honeymoon we're gonna come on and do a
big talk about the wedding but for now
i'm just going to tell you a little bit
show you some pictures we're going to
talk nba finals uh i love it what's
happening right now a little
disappointed in boston but we'll get
into that
and
um obi-wan i'm getting into that too but
for now welcome back
[Music]
all right y'all what's up i know i'm
just late late late late we're doing a
late version of the podcast right now i
uh
it's just
you know i just got married so i've been
dealing with all that so it's just like
um
what do you call it you know it is what
it is
you know what i mean so
i don't know
but i like doing i mean i got to do it
you know you got to do the podcast you
know you're committed i'm committed to
the fans committed to doing it but
anyways here we are riffin with griffin
um but before we start i want to give a
oh man oh no i
oh i don't have this anyways i got to do
it even though i don't have the graphic
up on the screen for you guys but uh
we'll give it up to our new sponsor
nutrafall nutrafall you can grow thicker
healthier hair and support my show go to
nutrafall.com men use code griffin to
save 15 off your first month
subscription
this is the best offer anywhere
let's get fifteen dollars off at
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l dot com slash men with
code griffin link's in the description
okay yeah see i might
my program crashed and then i had the
thing already set up ready to go
and then it like
you know oh well it doesn't matter i
just i won't have it on the screen but
it's in the description so any oh thank
you dan
and this is live right now we are live
i'm doing this live uh so welcome to the
podcast and as always subscribe
um
you know hit the notifications button so
you know you don't miss these uh live
episodes
and you know i'm on twitch make sure you
check me out twitch uh eric griffin
gaming if you want to be a member on
youtube be a member if you want to
subscribe on twitch subscribe on twitch
either way and
extra bonus content coming to you on
patreon so sign up now
at patreon.com
eric griffin
so
here we are and i did it guys got
married to
rachel
so next time i have her on we'll be
riffing with mrs griffin
it's pretty cool to be like i was on
stage the other day at a goddamn comedy
jam and i said okay so my wife and i was
like oh no i've never said that before
so that's how i'll be talking about it
right now you know so if i would say
rachel i might just be like hey my wife
so my wife
my wife was acting up today or i did
this to my wife or my wife told me this
you know so that's kind of cool to say
never thought i'd even say that in my
life but uh it is what it is so and
thank you all you guys out there can you
know i'm taking rich on the expensive
honeymoon so if you want to super chat
me i'll appreciate it
i'd be like this honeymoon is brought to
you by
youtube chat
thank you for all that you've done
so
thank you veronica i appreciate that but
it was first before i even get into um
before oh you guys and here's the ring
you know it's burning my finger when i
take it i got to put it back on
my
[Music]
[Laughter]
precious i wanted simple ring you know i
i actually even wanted a rubber one so
it just so it can really you know so it
doesn't really but this one's actually
pretty good you know what i mean
thank you robert paul and veronica the
honeymoon is brought to you by robert
paul and veronica with four dollars
total i will be able to take rachel to
mcdonald's thank you oh marco loca
i'm just teasing i appreciate everything
you guys do um yeah so i got the ring i
got my ring i got rachel needed just
like beautiful her her wedding band has
like all these diamonds and stuff on it
maybe i'll ask her to come down here
and stand in front of the camera so all
you guys that are listening you know i'm
gonna all you guys that are listening to
the podcast you listen to it first you
gotta check out youtube because i am
gonna show you some pictures from the
wedding
so
it was great all that stuff was great
but before i get into the wedding stuff
i gotta i gotta get all the the the
the stuff in my head that i just
that can i just [ __ ] about one thing
you know bitching with griffin that's
another uh segment oh and raquel rigg
thank you i appreciate that guys i
appreciate all these super chats this is
really great
so
you know so you guys know i got an
electric car i got a jag i got an
electric jag i didn't want to get a
tesla because i was trying to be
different because everybody's got a
tesla right so i got this electric jag
now jaguar makes a great car but in
terms of like the technology stuff it's
not the best for instance my car got 3g
in it like the 3g car internet that you
hook up to the car
inside the car you put like a sim card
in the car and you can get internet in
the car so all the stuff on the display
could be that right it's kind of cool
but the the technology's kind of
antiquated just eye pace so like you
know it's like you press it it's not
very responsive it could be better you
know
so the last five days my 3g gone it's
gone i i i keep hitting the reset on the
thing nothing works i keep reset and
then i call
i you know and then you can't first of
all
you can't get anything on the phone
anymore
like i had to google
like if you go to att's website and then
you go to like you know help you you
know it takes you to this like web thing
and then you call them and it's
it's a freaking
it's not even a real person you know i
should almost call right now online so
you guys can see what you have to deal
with when you call at t you know i mean
i have my phone hooked up you know what
let's do this because i want you to i
want you to see the nonsense you have to
deal with when you call att
you know what i mean
thank you for calling about atnt
promotions
para espanol marque numero ocho att
promotions what are you talking about
right
to order new service press one
if you're a current customer or i've
recently placed an order press two
if you're interested in finding out
about current promotions in your area
press three what is all this you know
what i mean
this isn't is this even the right number
that i doubt earlier to our new service
this is if you're calling about services
for your home press one well this is
this is
isn't even the right number
uh
now it's not is you know what's crazy is
now it's different
now it's different so like before
that
you call
all right anyways i'm not even going to
go through it again you call at t you
have to go through all these prompts
right
and then they go all right we'll send
you to the help desk and then the help
desk
someone sounds like a real person he's
like hi
hello
can i help you but a little weird right
and it's a robot and i'm like what
like just let me talk
let me know it's a robot
stop making it sound like i'm talking to
a real person when i'm not talking to a
real person that's frustrating you guys
know what i mean
like just be a just be a robot just be
like you know hi welcome to eight hands
because when you're trying to make it
like a person who's like hey thanks for
calling uh how can i help you then i it
fooled me at first because i was in my
car and i was like oh yeah okay thanks
man um
can i get uh i'm trying to find out
about my car i don't understand what
you're saying then i was like oh man i'm
talking to a goddamn robot what
and then it's like you go and then i'm
screaming at it operator
operator you know and then finally it
hits me with like okay uh we're gonna
get you to an operator
you know and then the operator is
they go well it's gonna be a 15 minute
wait do you want us to call you back or
do you want to stay on hold i'm like
okay call me back i wait 15 minutes they
call me back and it's still a robot and
then three four more minutes before
somebody actually got on the phone and
it wasn't even the department i needed
they had to send me someplace else
anyways
i finally get on the phone with the
three with the att vehicle
vehicle wi-fi people which for some
reason is a completely different branch
of att and you can't even log in with
the same login at the att website they
hit me with this
all the cell phone companies
they turn 3g off
so 3g is gone it's now a done antiquated
uh
software technology and they just went
alright bye bye 3g
but here's the problem
you you can't just upgrade to 4g 5g in
your car unless you have a 4g 5g antenna
and of course my 2019 version of this
expensive ass car doesn't have
the 4g 5g antenna of course
so now it's just i don't have internet
in my car and there's no way even to
like the onstar doesn't work you know i
know some of you are like what the
hell's onstar and then like
you know you can't
you can't uh you the software won't
upgrade because it's not connected to
the internet because this signal is not
you know so now i'm like i don't even
know
how to deal with this it's just i just
wanted to [ __ ] about it you know maybe
it's first world problems because not
everybody has a jaguar but i think this
is an issue with a lot of
cars
that even if it's an older car and you
had the 3g antenna in your car to grab
whatever services are coming into your
car the onstar the you know the the the
uh the gps and you know all that stuff
this
that's a brief wi-fi signal that's going
out to grab some information they turned
it off and they didn't even tell anybody
i didn't even get a memo i didn't even
get like so then oh and then i called
the lady
when i'm talking to the lady on the
phone now finally get somebody who's
obviously in zimbabwe or someplace okay
i don't know what she's obviously not in
the united states okay it's neither here
nor there i could care less it's only
get as long as you you could do the job
right
so
she's all like
she's all like i go well there's two
months left in my there's i have two
months left and i go well can you refund
me two of the months you know what i
mean i paid for the whole year
up front can i get two months back oh
well no you know you could just save
that for when you upgrade your i said
you can't upgrade the car you're not
gonna give me my two months back and
this is exactly what i said to her
y'all make a billion dollars you a
billion dollar company you could give me
30 back
and she was flummoxed by that okay
flummoxed and then she just was like
i could tell it was like the company
like line she was like oh no you've
already used 10 months and so and i was
just like you know what
whatever keep your money i mean
like the lack of customer service the
idea that you just don't want to make
this one person happy by giving them
thirty dollars is it like it boggles the
mind man
i'll say one thing for amazon they good
about that
you could call amazon like i remember i
bought this mixer and it was terrible it
wasn't proper it was only like 60
dollars i was first trying to do the
podcast and so i had this mixer right
i caught i want to send it back because
it stopped working
well it
i don't even know if it stopped working
it was working but it wasn't what i
wanted so i was like trying to return it
the guy on the phone was like i caught
it i get the guy he goes
i was i even had an attitude because i
was like oh this thing isn't you know
it's not doing what it said it was
supposed to do
it was something like that like it was
supposed to be bluetooth and it wasn't
and it said bluetooth but it didn't work
properly anyway
i have an attitude and the guy goes the
guy goes we'll just refund you the money
sir you know and i said uh okay
um
all right so you're gonna send me a
label for the box he goes
no sir we're just gonna refund you the
money keep the mixer and i was like
what i don't even want it you know what
i mean i was like in my mind i'm like
are you putting me out now i gotta store
this thing that i don't want or what am
i gonna do with it but at the same time
they just handled it he heard i was
about to have an attitude and he said
does that make you happy and i was like
yeah
even though
i wanted to be mad at his ass but i was
like oh the dude just gave me the mixer
for free so i was like okay and that's
how and that's how it uh that's how it
goes so
att get on board with this man
you could get you could just you
couldn't give me my like whatever is ten
dollars a month my little twenty dollars
you couldn't you couldn't just send me
twenty dollars
back just to be like so then i'll be
like oh you know what att is a good
company let me go let me go do that but
anyways that's the one i wanted to [ __ ]
about
keep you on your on the edge of your
seat let's
get into
the
wedding that i had with
hey joel
guys the wedding was fabulous
first of all
you know
i am i guess you kind of get a sense of
kind of how i am from watching the
podcast and stuff like that and you know
i'm a you know i i [ __ ] about things
and i you know i have strong opinions
about things and uh sometimes i'm a
little too serious about some things you
know
and i've kind of had to address just a
party the wedding it's just for the wife
you know it's just for the girl it
doesn't matter you know what i mean like
it's like for a guy you just kind of
show up and whatever but i got to tell
you it was the greatest day of my life
it really was
it was like emotional i'm i was like i
cried so many times it was
seeing all my friends there and
everything it was just it really was a
magical day it like okay so we had the
rehearsal
you know i'm just gonna briefly go over
it because i really want to get rachel
on too to like go over this but you know
you know so we had the rehearsal and it
was really hot and now we're nervous
because it's outside it was at sterling
hills this beautiful golf course in
camarillo it was a beautiful setting it
was like oh man magical but it was too
hot so now we're like oh my god cause my
mom was at the rehearsal she couldn't
stand the heat grandma couldn't stand
the heat rachel's grandma couldn't stand
he her dad has you know some issues
going on where like the heat was
bothering him
you know what i mean and it was just
like we were like worried about that we
were gonna have to get tents and we had
these little [ __ ] umbrellas and so
they was like oh no what's gonna happen
but the next day
it was like perfect there was a breeze
it was a little overcast so the sun was
blocked but yet still
bright out and nice so that was great
and so and then even after rehearsal i
started to be like oh wow this is gonna
be you know fun
um
you know and so then
we uh and then the day of the wedding
came and i was like all this preparation
and planning that's what really
overwhelms you it's all the preparation
it's all the like who's coming where's
everyone sitting are you spelling
everybody's names right you know then
like you know the venue wants a certain
number they want to know how many people
you're going to have and you know some
people aren't going to show up but they
want their money so they're like so
we're trying to decide do we tell them
95 even though it's 100 and we just
assume five people aren't going to show
up but then if they do show up where
they gonna sit it was just like like
you're just stressing out over that and
then all the families flying in where
they gonna stay who's coming where like
you know who's going to the wedding
who's not going to the wedding uh you
know it was it was all that and then
like you know uh you know
it's just a lot of logistics kind of get
in the way of the enjoyment and the and
the build up to it right
so but then when it finally was there oh
and then like two days before the
wedding rachel tries on her dress and
she's in the other room and then she
comes in here and she's you know i hate
it because she had to have
this custom-made dress
by this great designer mike costello and
shout out to him
uh and so she was worried she kind of
designed it herself with him you know i
never saw you know she went to four
fittings four fittings and then now when
it's time to get the dress she's crying
because the dress look she don't like
what the dress looks like
so i was like i didn't want to see it on
her so i said you want me to look at it
you know so i actually looked at the
dress beforehand and i was like if i'm
being 100 i can admit this now because
i didn't like how it looked
when she showed it to me in the plastic
and everything i was like oh my god
she's not gonna like that and then she
had her mom's dress there that she fit
got fitted for her just to take some
pictures right but she was like why
don't you i said well maybe you could
wear your mom's dresses she's like i
don't know what i'm wearing my mom's
just my mom's dress is hideous you know
she was like you know but i guess every
daughter would feel like that about her
mom's dress but her mom's dress was
beautiful too right so i'm like
concerned now and she's like so no you
know i have to hit her with the baby you
could wear a potato sack and you're
gonna look good you make everything look
good but honestly she doesn't make
everything look good her body's designed
for that kind of designer clothes and
stuff so you know i was just saying that
but at the same time i've seen her on
the runway in some nonsense and she make
it look good listen to me
nonsense that high fashion stuff it'll
make no sense to me okay and this was
just a simple white dress that had these
like i'll show it to you okay
so i'm concerned and i said to her well
you had four fittings what's going on
and then it was like she's not very
confrontational so she don't want to
like put her foot down except for with
me she only put her foot down with me
but she don't put her foot down with
anybody else so i encouraged her i was
like you need to hit him up this is your
wedding day you know so we did she hit
him up to the guy's credit he was like
send the dress so we ubered the dress
over so they could do some finishing
touches on it and then her friend amanda
shout out to amanda she went and picked
it up and brought it out to camarillo
okay and so i'm still i'm i'm concerned
to that point where i'm like damn how's
this gonna look you know what i mean
like how's this dress gonna look by the
time
um
uh it's it's time to get married you
know what i mean like when she's coming
down the aisle but i gotta tell you guys
man i'm gonna show it to you she
looked
awesome
okay
wait come on man i'm trying to get this
one picture it's like taking forever to
render all right here we go so
boom
and that and that angle right there
isn't even i can't even
really show like like real i'll show you
other pictures where it just like it
just came out really beautiful you know
what i mean
and
you know and so when i saw her walking
up with her dad
you know i started walking up with her
dad and i just was like i couldn't even
get like
like by the way
anybody just getting married
um
you know there's a few times the woman
wants you to cry
okay let me just give you some grown man
advice
all right actually we put this up right
now real world advice from a grown ass
man okay
your woman wants you to cry when you
first see her and she's walking up in
her dress that's one of the moments that
you get overwhelmed and swell with
emotion
i was emotional it's a long walk up so i
saw her and i was just like wow
but i couldn't get like that type of
emotion because i was so amazed at how
beautiful she looked
like
the dress was perfect
i like i was like is that even the same
dress so i was so amazed at like how
great it turned out and just what a like
how beautiful she looked i just was like
in awe when she was walking up with her
dad
you know
thanks brian for the super chat um i
didn't even know
you know what i mean and to the point
where you know i'm supposed to go shake
her dad's hand and be like thank you for
your you know thank you i couldn't even
do that because i was like just you know
what i mean but that's one of the
moments she said you didn't cry later
you know what i mean but i'm just
telling y'all now like what was really
going on but i was a blubbering idiot
during my
vows
[Laughter]
i couldn't get through those man it was
great and i went first and she headlined
you know what i mean she crushed it her
vows were great
so
you know so anyways
the uh
you know it was just the kind of thing
that i didn't know i was going to feel
the all the things that i felt like how
great it was and it really was
i just
i had such
like i say i was just overwhelmed with
emotions you know what i mean
so
i don't want to talk about it too much
because like i said i want to talk about
it with her but anyways let's just go
let me go let me go back and show you
some of the pictures again so you can
see
you know that's my so we did it
differently too so that's my cousin my
cousin alyssa and rachel's brother
michael
they were our best man and maid of honor
but
alyssa was with me and michael was with
her so we did it differently than most
people and we didn't have a big wedding
party because i didn't really want to do
that and here's some of the people that
were in the crowd that came to the show
that's my buddy chris chris delia came
to the wedding he was great
check out bobby you know i don't know
what devious look bobby has on his face
so in the comments right now if you want
to
like like what is it
like caption contest what is bobby lee
thinking right here
you know what i mean
like what is he possibly thinking about
so let's let's um
you know what i mean let's let's figure
that out you know oops i didn't want to
do that sorry
this is not what i wanted to do sorry
yeah so let's uh
let's
let's let's put that into so in the
captions right now not captions in the
comments you know if you want to if you
want to um
do that like let me know what do you
think
what do you think bobby's thinking right
now
in this picture
you know so
there was that
i'm just adjusting the screen right now
so i can move that around so yeah so
bobby was there
and then uh who else was there that's
matt rife and matt espinoza from jen to
gen shout out to them so that was fun
yeah but
also bobby wore a beanie to the wedding
right
oh man craziness i told you about them
there's rachel and her dad who's six
nine
you know and he's just such a jolly
happy dude and he listens to the podcast
i know you're listening right now ken so
shout out to you
um
rachel was like killing during her vows
and look at that beautiful smile that's
great
that's our cake and there's my buddy ben
seaward in the background right there
drinking a beer people were drinking we
had a beautiful cake the cake was red
velvet on top like two of them were red
velvet because i like red velvet and the
other one was like this
chocolate cherry that rachel liked
and these are all the boys that came to
the show baby came to the show came to
the wedding the wedding show uh leonard
robinson you know was there al madrigal
chris dalia jeremiah watkins andrew
santino
malcolm barrett ian edwards dean delray
bobby lee and rick glassman um everybody
who
and there's rachel oh the dance oh man
the father-daughter dance was great look
how beautiful she looks
then um this is me and my mom dancing
man guys
you know what i you know if you listen
to the podcast you know
i talk a lot about my mom has dementia
we're laughing right here but this was a
really emotional
i see i'm gonna get emotional now so let
me not
but this is really super emotional for
me i
i was crying
dancing with my mom
because i know she she knows what was
happening but at the same time it wasn't
the same
feeling i know she would have had
because this is what she always wanted
for me is to get married you know
and you know it was i mean i was crying
and she was like don't cry and i'm
thinking to myself you making me cry you
know what i mean but it was really
beautiful so we had a really good time
and a lot of people were just blubbering
during this and they want to act like
they weren't but they were
now there's kyle this is the only
workaholics person that showed up
[Laughter]
this is my only workaholics person that
showed up and so i sent a group text to
the boys with kyle and i said
right now this is kyle explaining to us
why you guys didn't show up
so
it was uh
but of course they all had a thing
adam's working anders brothers is
getting married too anders brother got
married the same weekend i think he got
married on the 10th in chicago and blake
you know he sent me a nice video message
explaining why he didn't show up because
his girl got a gig last minute and he
has he needed somebody to watch his
daughter so shout out to them though i
was just teasing but you know that i was
glad that that he showed up you know and
then this is me shaking you know when
you brought the dad up i'm laughing
right here because i'm like
i didn't even i'm shaking the day for
the people listening i'm shaking her
father's hand like you know how you do
that you like here's my daughter type of
thing but i i was standing there just
staring at her and somebody like had to
say rick had to say here go you know
what i mean so
um
and then there okay so this is a better
view of the dress you know so it you
know you know what i mean like she
designed this herself and it is just
she looked like so dope you know what i
mean
so
that was great
and then um this is our the both
families
you know there's my stepfather my mom
rachel her mom and her her dad so
yeah and last but not least
that's who the officiant was mr rick
glassman was the officia and he
did
fantastic
he really he really did it was really
great we were he he was crying i was
crying rachel was crying we had to pass
out kleenex
it was great he did a really great job
um
so
yeah
there is that and let's see do i have
another picture i don't think so
[Laughter]
george shut up okay
stop being
look that's what she wanted to wear she
designed it herself it is what it is
whoo
anyways um
yeah that's that and i guess so more
wedding stuff will come later i promise
but you know what before i do that man i
don't have this thing up you can see it
you can see the links and stuff down low
let's talk right now about neutral fall
neutral fall y'all it's not something
that i necessarily needed but i have so
many friends who are losing and losing
their hair you know my buddy one of my
good buddies jeff it was at the wedding
you know just bald as hell a lot of
people are out there bald i'm sure
there's a lot of bald guys listening
right now
um you could grow thicker healthier
and you can support my show by doing it
at the same time like you don't have to
choose between
between
better hair growth and your health
there's a holistic solution for men that
promotes both healthier hair and whole
body wellness
so that's like important it's one of the
reasons why i was like you know what i
want to tell fans of riffing with
griffin about this
you know neutral fall is the number one
dermatologist recommended hair growth
supplement clinically shown to improve
your hair growth thickness and visible
scalp coverage
those are the things you want right
so it's healthier for you
um
dermatologists recommend it and it's
going to help with that
hairline if that's something that is
important to you
all right
so make sure you check that out guys
physicians formulated using natural
medical grade ingredients neutral falls
drug-free patented technology provides
consistent reliable results without
compromising your sexual health
ooh who wants that right what's the
point of having hair if you can't
close the deal you can grow thicker
healthier hair and support our show by
going to nutrafall.com
men and enter the promo code griffin to
save 15 off your first month
subscription this is their best offer
anywhere and it's only available in u.s
customers for a limited time plus free
shipping on every order get 15 off at
nutrafall.com
men spelled n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l
dot com slash men promo code griffin
all the information is down below
okay guys um
let's get into
some other stuff
so i watched um wait let me put this up
on the screen here
all right so i don't know if you saw
if you saw a podcast two weeks ago
i was ranting and raving about obi-wan
okay loved it you know what i mean
i was like this is
a great show a first two episodes of
like really
like this nostalgia of star wars
i gotta tell you man
episode three and four
oof
just
like it's off the rails now okay
it's just off the rails
it's just
it's like
it's a television show
so i'm getting a sense that they're not
spending the kind of money let's say
they would spend on a movie
so especially a high budget special
effects movie that might be
you know 100 million dollars to get all
the effects because if you think about
it this is going to be six or six or
eight hours of footage which would
normally be like maybe three movies
right
so you're talking about three movie
budget of like you know who knows 250
million who knows how many millions of
dollars to make a really high-tech movie
they're not spending that kind of money
on this show therefore they have to use
other methods to
tell this story and i don't think
they're doing a very good job anymore
i think that it's like it's great to see
the main character that main guy who was
in the movies he gives it some
credibility but some of these other
characters man oh
like i'm telling you man i'm not going
to point anybody out but there's some
really bad acting going on like
i don't believe anything coming out of
their mouth
and so it is so distracting that i can't
even it's like ugh this is terrible
right
so
and in the storyline it's like i don't
know where they're going with this
it was cool to see darth vader but at
the same time it's like i think that
this could have been a better thing
because you totally get it it's coming
off the heels of
you know he you know
obi-wan was on the hill and he was like
i've already won don't do it i have the
high ground which don't make no sense to
me and then you know he cuts him in half
and he looks like he burns to death and
it looks like darth vader anakin
skywalker dies on that lava lava thing
but of course the emperor comes grabs
him saves him makes him a robot turns
him into darth vader uh 10 years later
now obi-wan is living with that he's
like
he's thinking how he failed
the jedi order is done
anakin his
his protege his padawan killed a bunch
of kids
he feels like a failure and it's now 10
years later and he's just off and then
the mother the father and the people
that have you know
taken leia in
while he's on this planet sort of
watching over luke they come like yo man
we need you so he's been living a
different life so i liked that i enjoyed
that like oh this is like a really like
down on his luck obi-wan who's has to
like he's in and then now the jedi are
being hunted by by the empire and he
comes to find out later he's gonna find
out oh darth vader's hunting him
so when he finds out that anakin's alive
and he's now darth vader
he's like
that's that should be like a oh wow and
you know but they're just not delving
into that i don't i'm just not
emotionally attached anymore like i said
i think the performances are rocky
they're real shaky i will say i can see
you know yeah they're shaky
[Laughter]
you know they are shaky the main guy
is he's great mcgregor whatever his name
is
um
you know
i know i'm terrible with names
uh but yeah he's carrying it
um but
there's some other performances
surrounding him that are just not good
it's not good okay
i wish it was the people that make
mandalorian that that would have taken
this taken it over and moved on with it
but
i don't know if i'm gonna be able to sit
through the rest of it you know what i
mean because this is oof
oof oof oof is all i can say about that
and if you're watching it
tell me what you think about it it's not
people say conor mcgregor i know it's
not
what's his name
i'm about to look it up because you you
[ __ ] in chat
you know
i know i'm terrible at it
um
disney plus obi wan disney plus
yeah how do you even it's mcgregor see
but how do you say his first name
you know i don't know how to say his
first name ewin e1 e1 regret i don't
know
whatever i'm terrible at this i didn't
realize that it's actually hayden
christensen
who's playing darth vader in this which
is pretty interesting that he did that
even all all you
know um
ewon
somebody put the like phonetical e e e
wayne
e wayne
whatever i'm so sorry to him shout out
to that guy
um
yeah it's just
there's there's so much about this
series that
like i feel like they dropped the ball
like there's a rich
story to be told
from the moment that
that anakin skywalker becomes darth
vader
that his rise in power
and his seeking because of course he
would want to seek revenge right
because his you know the guy left him on
a freaking lava planet to burn to death
so there's a rich thing there that i
just think that they're sort of like
they sort of half-ass trying to explain
and i
i don't know it started great i think
the first two episodes are really
fantastic and then it just goes off the
rails guys
but you know it is
like i say all the time it is what it is
all right
okay
enough of that
um you know sorry it's a chill episode
today because i just like i said i've
just been doing like
living in the wedding with the you know
just i'm on a still on a wedding high
and
and just you know so let's but let's
talk about the nba finals
got to talk about the nba finals so
it's it was tied up
um so all the storylines i used to talk
about before uh let's talk about them
now because it is they are they are
right there i love both these teams
because i love the the stories that they
create for both teams
on one hand with golden state golden
state is proving they are a great team
that they can get different pieces in
this team and they can be successful as
long as they have their core they're
proving that it wasn't kevin durant it
was golden state
and kevin durant's performance since he
left golden state is showing that uh
being with golden state it's very
helpful that dude is an extreme talent
but in terms of like being able to lead
a team
to the promised land golden state
maximized and utilized kevin durant's
skill set to its fullest with their game
plan with the passing and you have to
remember
kevin durant the extreme talent that he
is do you know even how much better he
is when you got klay thompson and the
two greatest shooters of all time on the
wings you can't double off them because
they'll hit the i mean it's just the
whole system was set up for everybody to
be super successful and someone with
that sort of skill set is obviously
going to shine and he did but it's
showing that he's already had enough we
have enough kevin durant
information at go at okc
how he couldn't beat lebron how he
choked against golden state how the team
talked about the team choked against
golden state up 3-1 and so now he went
to golden state successful and now boom
couldn't win you know he needed his
teammates
and now look what happened this year got
swept by boston okay so that's the
storyline for golden state
they're now legitimizing their
legacy they're legitimizing their
championship
um
they're run this dynasty it's a legit
dynasty
they've been to the championship six out
of eight years i don't like golden state
but i love this story now the other
story for steph curry he's having his
like and i saw this on another sports
show and i i totally agree with it it's
like a kobe moment remember when kobe
was with the lakers with shaq it was
always shaq's the best shaq's the best
they want him because of shag shack
kobe's dairy he's robin he's robin
then
they get rid of shaq because kobe was
like get rid of me or get rid of him
they picked kobe shaq's gone kobe takes
the lakers and he leads them to two
championships and he was the reason
that's all he wanted steph curry is
doing that right now he didn't win the
mvp
uh with iguodala which he should have
won the mvp all right like they like if
you look at his numbers in that finals
they were great numbers and then and
then iguodala won because he stopped
lebron lebron averaged like 36 15 and
10. some something like that
like his stats in that finals was like
did you stop him so anyway that's just a
testament to how great lebron is by the
way but anyways
steph curry right now he's like
we're gonna win because i'm the best
player on this team
i i i garner the most attention because
even the last game he went over nine but
it don't matter because when he's on the
court you have to
close out on him you have to he he
garners so much attention that it makes
it easier for someone like andrew
wiggins to shine even more because
everybody's concerned about curry he's
averaging over 30 points in this finals
if they win he is hands down the the the
finals mvp and they would have won the
championship because of him he's having
his moment i love that story
right boston on the other side
i picked boston to win this i think
they're just physically more dominating
but they are choking man
uh jason tatum what are you doing bro
what are you doing
get it together this is the kind of dude
that can have 45 in a game like this
he is not getting the job done golden
state is outplaying them at their own
game they're being physical they're
banging inside they're making it
difficult for any anybody to get a shot
off they're playing boston's game
against them and they're winning it
i still think boston can win the series
this is the first time in the playoffs
they've lost back-to-back games
and they've already won two games in a
row twice
so
this is it
boston obviously has to win this game
six they have to and i think that they
will and i think they're gonna win it in
convincing fashion i think they're gonna
come out they're gonna shake off this
rust and they're gonna come out in front
of their home fans and let everybody
know why they're in the championship i
love their story they swept kevin durant
and kyrie irving they beat the champs
okay even though they didn't have chris
milton they still beat the champs and
arguably the best player right now onto
takumpo then they beat the number one
seed and jimmy butler was outplaying
everybody jimmy butler should have been
the eastern conference mvp the way he
was playing they beat them and now
they're in the finals against this
dynasty team who is like taking them to
the brink if they beat them what a story
i think it's just uh it'll be it would
be a really fantastic story for them too
i love both these stories
um
you know what i mean
so
wait i gotta give somebody a time out uh
i'm just like now that i'm married i'm
just like i'm not put i just i'm moving
past like all the haters like there's so
many like like really lonely loser
haters out there you know what i mean
they are they're in reddit feeds and
they're like you know it's like all
these people that like they they
literally have like this is all they
have to do is just to be an [ __ ]
i'm done with it so you just time out or
you're getting blocked and i'm moving on
with my life because i'm
winning um and remember you're watching
me
you remember you're
you're
watching me
and you're just on your little keyboard
talking [ __ ]
it's pretty sad but anyways
um
i think these are both great stories i i
the games have been great
you know whoever wins like if boston
wins
to me it's gonna be and jason tatum will
be the the the finals mvp because the
only way they're gonna win
is that dude gotta show up i'm talking
about he gotta have 40 in both these
games game six and game seven he gotta
have 40 or he got to have a game like 35
15 and 10. he got to have games like
that and if he does that he'll solidify
his mvp but right now he is not looking
good
he's not so jason
get
it together i support
and and like i say i'm i don't want to
support the golden state warriors
but i'm going i'm i love both stories i
just love it i love how these stories
have far-reaching implications
uh you know did if boston wins this
would be one of the hardest roads to the
championship ever probably if you think
about it like i said they beat they beat
the season they beat the the preseason
favorites one of the the one of if not
the greatest player in the game
alongside not to kenpo kevin durant with
kyrie irving his talent they swept them
you know what i mean beat the champs
beat the number one seed and now if they
beat golden state what an achievement
that would be so it's great stories all
the way around
so
we'll see
we will see uh how that uh how it all
plays out so because by the next time
um you see me i will have come back from
a honeymoon uh we're going on a
honeymoon too guys
to finish off the the wedding talk and
this episode
i'm going on a honeymoon
uh i think we're gonna go
to i guess does it matter if i tell you
guys yeah we're going to cancun it
doesn't matter you don't know where
[Laughter]
cut two i
cut to one of these loser haters it's
like i found you montiz i failed you
like what are you doing here you spend
all this money just to be a hater
so um
yeah it's gonna be
you know i'm looking forward to that you
know i figure this is gonna be it's
gonna be i just feel like this is gonna
be my only wedding my only honeymoon you
know i just in closing just want to be
like
just tell you guys how happy i am with
my beautiful bride
my new wife um
i feel complete
i feel
there's like a there's like a calmness
i went to do comedy the other night and
it was like the goddamn comedy jam you
know and i was singing a song and i was
thinking about her when i was singing
the song and and i just felt like oh man
what else there's what is there left to
do now except for like start a family
you know but this is how you start a
family i've started a family and i just
feel
it feels
like man what what was i missing
and it was this you know
it's like you can make money and you can
like you know have a career and and i
did i i i am very happy with my life you
know to i started comedy at 30 years old
man i started really late
you know i and and then so the last 20
years i've done so many things i've been
in like a blockbuster movie i've been on
television shows i've been you know what
i mean i i'm on a podcast i toured a
country i i'm recognizable like you know
people i have fans people come up to me
they're like oh you know that's like all
that stuff is the kind of thing you
dream about you know what i mean
i'm just a weird guy from la right
just a weird funny guy from l.a and it
was like i thought oh you define
yourself by what you do but what i
realize is you should define yourself by
the beautiful people you have in your
life
and
that's where i'm at now
so shout out in kudos to mrs griffin
i like saying that
the beautiful the vivacious
rachel griffin once the paperwork goes
through
and the marriage license comes back she
will be mrs griffin but anyways guys
um
yeah
i'm not i don't need to do the full on
i don't need to do the full-on um
hour you know what i mean
this has been
this has been good enough wait where's
my out outro music here it is gonna get
the outro music
anyways
i want to thank everybody i want to
thank all the super chat people that was
really dope with you guys you know what
i mean i really appreciate that and look
if you want to become a member on
youtube become a member you know you'll
get some exclusive access and um
you know stuff like that uh when i got
you know
stuff going on
and then you know like i say make sure
you subscribe
love that
make sure you
hit the notifications button so you know
when i'm going live
hit me up on twitch i'm on twitch a lot
guys and if you want to get uh other
content patreon
good probably gonna do like wiggy was
there wiggy showed up to the wedding
that was great i'm gonna show other
pictures on another episode of like i'll
show more pictures i'm gonna have a
full-on wedding episode that one might
be for patreon only with like all the
insides and outs so make sure you check
that out if you're really interested in
that but guys i want to thank you for
being here
you guys are fabulous
i like all of you thanks for the
trolling thanks for the positivity
thanks for the the super chats and
thanks for being here every week
on whiffenwood griffin
and i will see you all
next week
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you see
[Music]
me
[Music]
2022
[Music]
see y'all
[Music]
[Music]
you